[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola que tal bienvenidos a diario de
copas entramos ya en la recta final de
la eurocopa y la copa américa estos son
nuestros titulares
la argentina jugará contra brasil al
final de la copa américa este sábado la
albiceleste eliminó en penaltis a
colombia con una actuación estelar donde
messi y emiliano martínez como ganó
argentina el partido hay un balance
positivo para los cafeteros
italia vuelve a una final nueve años
después de aburrá superó a una buena
españa en penaltis el de roberto mancini
sufrieron pero un fallo de morata el de
los 12 pasos
condenó a la roja
e inglaterra busca este miércoles
cumplirás de su afición en londres y
clasificar a su primera final en una
eurocopa de naciones frente a una
dinamarca que quiere repetir la gloria
de 1992 analizamos la previa del
encuentro
[Música]
argentina y brasil van a jugar una final
de copa américa 14 años después brasil
busca repetir título y argentina quiere
acabar con una sequía de 28 años y para
analizar esta victoria de la albiceleste
un día más estamos con sara castro
director del diario 'as' colombia
gracias ahora hola juan como siempre un
gusto si un partido muy interesante el
que vimos anoche entre colombia y
argentina
sin duda argentina se impuso por lo que
ha construido a lo largo del torneo y
ayer me llamó la atención que scaloni
mencionaba mucho esto de saber sufrir y
saber sufrir en estas etapas sin embargo
me parece que argentina llevo mucho
tiempo este sufrimiento del partido lo
que hizo colombia fue llevarle un lugar
muy incómodo durante la primera parte lo
que pasa es que el equipo de rueda les
sigue faltando saber qué hacer con la
pelota pero aparece messi una vez más y
sobre todo un equipo que entiende como
rodearlo y que si bien no tuvo el
dominio del partido hasta la entrada de
di maría al final que empieza a poner
las cosas de nuevo en orden para el
equipo de scaloni si supo controlarlo y
luego la tanda de penales en la que
martínez evidentemente fue el granero
ha demostrado argentina y sobre todo
scaloni que sabe reaccionar a los
partidos corrigió en cuartos en fase de
grupos y ha corregido también en cuerdos
muestra que cuando sufre ha sabido
reaccionar con cambios y le han dado
resultado sí para mí ayer fue un poco
tarde y eso es lo que me llamó la
atención creo que argentina no es un
equipo para estar fuera de dominio tanto
tiempo en el partido independientemente
de que colombia no lo supiera aprovechar
y eso es extraño en una selección que
está llamada a proponer un poco más y
teniendo además a messi como una de sus
figuras
yo creo que scaloni después de dos años
ya está encontrando un equipo con fichas
nuevas y con fichas que saben cómo
funcionar ayer sin duda la gran figura y
quién puso más en problemas a la defensa
argentina fue luís díaz que se hizo un
partidazo pero independientemente de eso
creo que bueno argentina está sabiendo
llevar los partidos se le había
cuestionado esas esos cambios en el
estado de ánimo durante un mismo partido
sigue siendo esa una deuda pero pero
bueno muy bien y justo clasificado
además para uno de esos partidos que
todo el mundo espera
el guión de momento es argentina lo
siguió manteniendo la final que sea
marcar y luego sufrir en una final eso
ya es otra cosa quiero que hablemos un
poco acerca de colombia porque colombia
llegaba a esta copa américa con apenas
dos partidos por parte de la nueva era
de reinaldo rueda cuál es el balance
para esta selección colombia a grandes
rasgos es positivo sin embargo falta
mucho trabajo que es lo positivo el
nivel competitivo que ha mostrado el
equipo los partidos ante uruguay y ante
argentina son prueba de ello desde lo
mental estuvieron muy fuertes y muy
alineados con el entrenador eso ya
genera un cambio con lo que se venía
viendo en el anterior proceso y en
niveles individuales altísimos lo de
barrios es destacable creo que es el
mejor 5 del torneo bueno junto a
casemiro que también ha hecho una muy
buena copa américa
luís díaz ya lo mencionábamos santos
borre también como una ficha muy
importante no sólo en el frente de
ataque sino en labores en más tácticas y
creo que eso es con lo que se queda
rueda al final los resultados eran más
de lo esperado en el sentido en el poco
trabajo pocas unidades de trabajo para
el entrenador y falta ver
este tercer puesto pues va a ser como la
cereza al pastel si logra conseguirlo
aunque hay que trabajar muchísimo más en
lo colectivo el cumplió con que iba a
tener la pelota la tuvo pero hay que
saber qué hacer con ella pero por lo
menos ya lo que decidí hacer es que
parece que le creen al técnico
recordemos economía venía de dos
goleadas en los últimos partidos con
queiróz si hay un cambio evidente y como
siempre hemos dicho el objetivo final de
esta copa américa para varias
selecciones incluida colombia es
clasificar al mundial de qatar-2022
cambio de actitud de mentalidad y
competitividad es que salirle a jugar
argentina incluso con el gol que recibió
temprano ayer y cómo reacciona el equipo
es muy importante yo creo que esto de
recuperar el adn de la identidad no lo
hemos visto en el juego pero sí en la
convicción de los jugadores de estar del
lado del entrenador creo que es positivo
además de los resultados que ya había
obtenido en la eliminatoria así que lo
que queda es clasificarse a qatar
podemos decir que hay esperanza para
colombia para terminar este bloque sobre
argentina en la final y colombia
escuchemos lo que dijeron anoche al
término del encuentro
y david ospina
no obviamente nos pusimos en 30 rápido
pero ellos jugaron un gran partido
metieron todo lo que podían colombia la
verdad un buen segundo tiempo nosotros
tuvimos un par de ocasiones para
meterlos a uno y que al partido nos
llevaron de vuelta a los penales que
ellos son muy fuertes y bueno esto es
cuestión de suerte a mí me tocó ser el
glorioso mismo seguimos en lo que
queremos nosotros tenemos un gran
objetivo
al final que llegar a qatar y bueno todo
eso que se ha hecho en esta fabricación
muy valioso para lo que viene yo creo
que esto vamos a hacer vídeo con todo lo
que está viviendo con todo el esfuerzo
que se ha hecho yo creo que nosotros
vamos al kilos con con este trabajo
habidos bien hablando con la celebración
de los futbolistas argentinos justo
detrás de él pasamos ahora hablar de la
eurocopa con la victoria de italia sobre
españa en penaltis también después de un
partido que terminó con empate aún no
hay muchos aspectos similares entre
estos dos duelos entre argentina de
colombia e italia y españa que ya vamos
a analizar la azzurra venció por 4 a 2
en penaltis con un fallo de álvaro
morata que condenó a la roja antes que
se había adelantado detalle precisamente
morata había conseguido en la y
para italia al igual que argentina
terminó aguantando en este partido pero
de una manera muy distinta claro tiene
muchos más argumentos italia lo que
demostró es que no necesita la pelota
para ganar que también puede ser esa
otra italia ellos habían necesitado la
pelota para poner ritmo y para
mostrarnos ese juego valiente
emocionante del que ya habíamos hablado
pero ayer con un gran partido en lo
táctico por parte de españa confiaron en
sus defensas confiaron en su portero y
creo que llevan a cabo un resultado
necesitaron tres toques y una contra
armada por el portero porque son
clínicos porque saben cómo aprovechar
las oportunidades mientras españa tenía
la pelota sin lograr hacer daño también
la participación para mí de erick garcía
en ese gol de pieza para españa' también
queda un balance positivo
luis enrique defiende su equipo desde
primer momento terminan haciendo un buen
papel un equipo nuevo con varios
jugadores que nunca habían llegado una
distancia tan alta en un torneo
continental sí me gusta mucho una
expresión que usaron varios periodistas
españoles ayer es que hay selección una
selección que llegó muy cuestionada con
rupturas en general con la hinchada sin
confianza en el equipo y demostró que
tiene un grandísimo entrenador
el partido táctico de ayer de españa fue
impresionante sin dejar jugar a los
volantes a jorgito ave ratti y eso fue
clave para la manera como luego insisto
italia tiene muchísimos argumentos y lo
demostró
pero también consagra jugadores como
pedro como danny olmo y sobre todo el
alma y estandarte del equipo que es
busquets hay una idea clara hay trabajo
le falta en ambas áreas pero creo que
hay mucho y hay habrá un equipo que va a
competir muy bien en qatar
seguramente para terminar este bloque
hoy habló manuel locatelli que comenzó
cerrando el primer penalti para italia y
luego terminó sonriendo eso dijo
yo hoy he llorado lágrimas de tristeza y
de felicidad al mismo tiempo al final
del partido estaba en un momento tal que
ni siquiera me reconocía estaba nervioso
y emocionado al mismo tiempo fue una
alegría increíble y una emoción
fantástica para mí es un sueño hecho
realidad ahora podemos seguir soñando
para ganar y traer a casa el título
el portal de casa del rapero
palabras del jugador del sassuolo y ya
dentro de poco comienza en londres la
otra semifinal de la euro entre
inglaterra y dinamarca un duelo marcado
por toda la presión de los ingleses con
la retórica de it's coming home el
fútbol vuelve a casa y el sueño de
avanzar a una euro a una final de euro
por primera vez
dinamarca ya ganó este torneo en 1992 y
en la previa el portero danés kasper
schmeichel ya le puso picante un poco al
asunto poniendo en duda eso de que oye a
lo mejor no es tan cierto de que el
fútbol vuelve a casa porque nunca han
ganado la euro si hizo esta pregunta un
poco en broma son 55 años sin llegar a
una final para inglaterra y eso pesa sin
embargo esta generación combina dos
cosas muchos jugadores talentosos pero
también un equipo que se sabe defender
muy bien evidentemente hay muchísima
expectativa por lo que pueda hacer
dinamarca porque durante el torneo ha
mostrado que es un equipo que siempre
busca atacar y que además tiene muchas
maneras de hacerlo jueguen corto juegan
largo vamos a ver si rompe esas líneas
de presión también jugando en largo como
lo ha hecho en otras oportunidades
inglaterra pues llega con la valla
invicta eso habla de una tendencia de
saudita la manera como le gusta jugar y
qué es lo que prioriza pero también
tiene jugadores absolutamente
desequilibrado
como esterlino como yo que ya lo hemos
visto que en una conexión pueden hacer
mucho daño y dinamarca aferrándose a ese
espíritu de lo que pasó con una de sus
estrellas
con cristian edición al comienzo de esta
eurocopa cerramos por ahora este bloque
de la eurocopa pero hay más noticias en
torno a la euro ya la copa américa que
analizamos aquí en hielo de copas y
comenzamos hablando del francés antoine
griezmann porque la empresa de
videojuegos konami decidió cancelar el
contrato que tenía con el jugador del
barcelona por el polémico vídeo de 2019
en el que griezmann yustman dembélé se
burlan con comentarios racistas de unos
empleados de un hotel en japón ambos
futbolistas ya pidieron perdón
los penaltis entre italia y españa
fueron el evento televisado más visto en
lo que va de año en el país ibérico con
una cuota de pantalla que llegó a
alcanzar el 72,9 por ciento en promedio
11,7 millones de telespectadores vieron
la derrota de la selección de luis
enrique en semifinales
el delantero brasileño de jesús se
perderá la final del sábado contra
argentina después de que la conmebol
confirmara las dos fechas de suspensión
para el jugador del manchester city tras
su tarjeta roja contra el chileno
eugenio mena en cuartos de final para
terminar estará rápidamente brasil ha
mostró que tiene bastantes variantes
quizás no le haga tanta falta cabría
jesús para la final sí yo creo que es
una baja que a lo largo del torneo ti te
ha sabido cómo suplir porque esto es lo
que ha demostrado que tiene muchas
variantes muchos jugadores para rotar y
además se nos vienen muchos días de
análisis aquí en diario que si se harán
muchísimas gracias como siempre gracias
ustedes quédense porque se vienen
enfrente 4 un especial sobre el
asesinato del presidente de ti y yo en
el mois gracias por estar con nosotros